bien à chers collègues nous sommes très
heureux d'accueillir aujourd'hui
Monsieur Thomas Thévenoud en tant qu'
ancien député médiateur de la crise
entre les taxis et les VTC entre février
et juin 2014 auteur de la proposition de
loi relative au taxi et aux voitures de
transport avec chauffeur devenu la loi
du premier octobre 2014 Rolex Steve au
taxi et au VTC qui porte son nom
monsieur le ministre je vous souhaite la
bienvenue je vous remercie de vous être
rendu disponible pour répondre à nos
questions dans cette salle que je crois
que vous connaissez très bien nous avons
entamé en février les travaux de nos
commissions d'enquête sur les
révélations des uber-files l'ubérisation
son lobbying et ses conséquences vous le
savez à partir du 10 juillet 2022
plusieurs membres du consortium
international de journalisme
d'investigation on publie ce qu'il est
désormais convenu d'appeler les uberfils
s'appuyant sur 124000 documents internes
à la société uber dater de 2013 à 2017
cette enquête a dénoncé un lobbying
agressif du beurre pour implanter en
France comme don de nombreux pays des
véhicules de transport avec chauffeurs
des VTC venant concurrencer le secteur
traditionnel du transport public
particulier personne réservées
jusqu'alors au taxi dans ce contexte
notre commission d'enquête a deux objets
d'une part pour objet d'identifier
l'ensemble des actions de lobbying
menées par uber pour pouvoir s'implanter
en France le rôle des décideurs publics
de l'époque et mettre des
recommandations concernant l'encadrement
des relations entre décideurs publics et
représentants d'intérêt et d'autre part
pour ambition d'évaluer les conséquences
économiques sociales environnementales
du développement du modèle uber en
France et les réponses apportées à
apporter par les décideurs publics en la
matière votre audition nous intéresse
pour répondre à ces deux préoccupations
de notre commission d'enquête et je sais
que vous avez énormément travaillé à
l'époque mais aussi depuis sur ce sujet
qui vous passionne particulièrement vous
avez dit dans une interview qu'il avait
changé votre vie et votre trajectoire
professionnelle donc nous serons très
intéressés d'entendre vos
recommandations actuelles sur
l'ubérisation sur le dialogue social au
sein du secteur sur l'équilibre à
trouver entre l'innovation et la
protection le droit social
avant de vous entendre et de vous faire
réagir sur sur ces sujets et avant
d'entamer l'échange j'aimerais tout de
même vous poser deux questions assez
précises sur l'époque en question des
hubert-five et votre perspective en tant
que député puis ministre et médiateur
bien sûr sur sur ces sujets avant qu'on
parle du fond et des propositions
opérationnelles et politiques que l'on
peut proposer dans le cadre de cette
commission d'enquête
est-ce que durant les débats sur
lesquels vous dont vous avez été un
acteur central à l'époque est-ce que
vous avez le sentiment que certains
acteurs du débat étaient sous influence
de lobby et que leur prise de position
publique ou privées étaient liés à une
influence culte de lobby ou est-ce que
nous étions en présence selon vous de
différence politique idéologique sincère
peut-être
discutable mais sincère ça c'est ma
première question et ma deuxième
question
toujours
temps ce sens là est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment que les débats qui ont animé
la majorité de l'époque gouvernement
comme par Le Mans
on fait l'objet d'une forme d'opacité
dans les prises de position des uns et
des autres dans les actions des uns et
des autres ministres ou parlementaires
ou est-ce qu'ils étaient on a fait
l'oeuvre de de débat ouvert transparent
avec des prises de position assumée des
uns et des autres et le cas échéant de
compromis au sein du gouvernement
notamment lors des différents états la
vôtre et puis celles qui ont suivi à
Macron ou à gang je vais vous poser ces
deux premières questions déjà pour
planter un peu le décor la rapporteur
bien sûr à des questions si là dessus
mais je souhaite pas personnellement
qu'on passe toute l'heure qu'on a devant
nous là-dessus et qu'on puisse se
concentrer sur ce qu'on peut faire
aujourd'hui mais j'aimerais d'abord vous
entendre là-dessus et puis après bien
sûr vous laissez la parole sur le reste
avant de vous laisser la parole je
rappelle que cette audition est ouverte
à la presse qu'elle est retransmise en
direct sur le site de l'Assemblée
nationale et avant de vous laisser la
parole pour vos propos liminaires et
entamer les échanges je vous rappelle
que l'article 6 de l'ordonnance du 17
novembre 1958 relative au fonctionnement
des assemblées parlementaires impose aux
personnes auditionnées par une
commission d'enquête de prêter serment
de dire la vérité toute la vérité rien
que la vérité je vais donc vous inviter
monsieur le ministre à activer votre
micro levier à la main droite et dire je
le jure
je le jure merci beaucoup je vous laisse
la parole
bien merci monsieur le président madame
le rapporteur mesdames messieurs
n'y voyez pas une évolution politique de
ma part mais je siégeais un peu plus à
gauche dans cette salle
bon c'est la configuration du jour donc
je la respecte mais vous l'avez dit ça
me rappelle évidemment beaucoup de de
souvenirs quand je suis arrivé dans
cette salle en juin 2012 en tant que
député de Saône-et-Loire et membre de la
commission des finances et j'ai donc été
nommé
médiateur dans le conflit entre les
taxis et les VTC
je vous raconte un petit peu l'histoire
et et je répondrai à vos questions
précises monsieur le Président j'ai été
nommé le 10 février ou plus exactement
le directeur de cabinet de du Premier
ministre de l'époque le Premier ministre
s'appelait Jean-Marc Ayrault le direcab
s'appelait Christophe Chantepie m'a
appelé c'était un lundi matin en général
j'étais plutôt en circonscription et se
trouve que ce jour là j'étais à Paris me
demandant de me trouver à 10h à la
Maison de la Chimie au pied de l'estrade
où le Premier ministre avait une
proposition à me faire j'ai donc mis une
cravate je suis allé Maison de la Chimie
et Jean-Marc Ayrault m'a proposé d'être
médiateur dans ce conflit entre les
taxis et les VTC je tiens à dire tout de
suite que ni mon père ni mon grand-père
ni mon grand oncle n'ont été taxi je ne
connaissais rien à ce sujet qui a depuis
vous l'avez rappelé changé ma vie
j'ai été nommé pour des qualités
extras politiques pour
ma capacité ma rondeur m'a-t-on dit j'ai
hésité j'ai hésité pendant deux heures
avant d'accepter cette médiation et
finalement alors que tout le monde me
disait qu'il fallait pas prendre cette
médiation que c'était mission impossible
de trouver un compromis entre les taxis
et les VTC
et bien finalement j'ai accepté
le gouvernement quand un gouvernement
nomme un médiateur un député médiateur
dans un conflit social souvent il a une
idée derrière la tête il a une piste
d'atterrissage là il y avait pas de
piste d'atterrissage du tout le
gouvernement était complètement dans le
brouillard et il y avait même pas de
piste d'atterrissage pour le président
de la République parce que à l'époque le
président de la République ce jour-là il
était dans la Silicon Valley en train de
rencontrer Mark Zuckerberg et Travis
calanic ça ne s'invente pas et
l'obsession de l'Elysée c'était comment
trois jours après le jeudi après-midi il
allait pouvoir atterrir entre Roissy et
Orly qui était tous deux bloqué par les
taxis
le périphérique était bloqué des
violences avaient eu lieu et le
gouvernement c'était fourvoyer dans deux
options qui avaient été repoussées
consécutivement par le Conseil d'État et
l'Autorité de la concurrence d'abord le
prix minimum pour les VTC
et puis
un délai de 15 minutes minimum pour les
courses VTC ces deux solutions avaient
été repoussées
et donc on était dans une situation de
blocage et quand j'ai interrogé le
directeur de cabinet
ça commence à répondre à votre question
sur l'influence quand j'ai interrogé le
directeur de cabinet du premier ministre
pour savoir ce qu'il fallait faire et ce
qu'il y avait une piste d'atterrissage
il m'a dit tout est possible y compris
la fin des taxis et le rachat des
licences par l'État
ce qui coûtait de mémoire 3 milliards et
demi de l'époque
donc le gouvernement n'avait aucune
ligne de conduite et moi ce qu'on m'a
dit c'est d'abord reçoit tout le monde
écoute tout le monde pour trouver une
une solution et je dois dire que
aujourd'hui
rétrospectivement je pense que si je
n'étais pas intervenu
[Musique]
moi j'avais jamais pris de VTC c'est un
député de mon groupe politique qui m'a
incité à le faire je croyais d'ailleurs
que qu'on allait être ensemble cet
après-midi c'est Luc Bello qui m'a
proposé d'aller à un apéritif avec le
président de la République à l'Élysée on
a pris un VTC entre l'Assemblée
nationale et l'Élysée c'est la première
fois que je montais dans un uber de ma
vie
et lui il était grand consommateur
certains députés étaient grands
consommateurs de VTC certains
journalistes adoraient parler des VTC
c'est cette ambiance là qu'on ne connaît
plus aujourd'hui parce que des choses
ont beaucoup changé
dans laquelle je vais être immergé en
étant nommé médiateur avec aucune piste
d'atterrissage et franchement ça a été
de février 2014 jusqu'à vote de la loi
1er octobre 2014 le gouvernement n'avait
pas de ligne en vérité
il y avait des influences diverses au
sein du gouvernement pour faire simple
le ministère de l'Intérieur
les différents ministres Manuel Valls
d'abord Bernard Cazeneuve ensuite été
pro taxi très pro taxi l'intérieur
considérait que les taxis étaient de la
propriété du ministère de l'intérieur
j'ai même été convoqué je me souviens
par le préfet de police de l'époque de
Paris
chez lui je n'avais jamais mis les pieds
à la préfecture de police pour me dire
qu'il ne fallait pas toucher à une
oreille des taxis et puis de l'autre
côté vous aviez le pôle Bercy qui était
lui favorable à la disruption à la
révolution du mérite à Hubert à l'époque
Emmanuel Macron n'est pas ministre de
l'Économie quand je suis nommé
médiateur
le président de la République
d'aujourd'hui et secrétaire général
adjoint de l'Élysée
mais il fait partie je dirais de cette
tendance au sein de l'appareil
gouvernemental
favorable à Hubert et au VTC et donc moi
mon rôle c'est d'essayer
en très peu de temps le plus vite
possible
déjà de lever les blocages de faire en
sorte accessoirement que le Président de
la République puisse atterrir ce qui
sera le cas le jeudi à 15 heures
pour une raison très simple c'est que je
décide enfin j'appelle le Premier
ministre je me souviens très bien de ce
coup de fil en disant à Jean-Marc
Ayrault il faut stopper
l'immatriculation des VTC à l'époque on
immatricule 1000 véhicules par mois le
flot est incessant je rappelle que les
VTC ont été créés dans une loi sur le
tourisme à l'époque ça s'appelle des
véhicules de tourisme avec chauffeur non
pas de transport
c'est une loi sur le tourisme qui a créé
ce statut là et Hubert a décidé de faire
de Paris sa cible favorite vous
connaissez sans doute l'anecdote
historique Travis scalénique était à
Paris lors d'un sommet de la tech il
s'était assez d'occasion ne trouve en
patte taxi qu'il aurait décidé de faire
de Paris et de la France une de ces
cibles commerciales favorites et donc
nous sommes confrontés à ce problème
politiquement la majorité est confrontée
à ce problème vous avez deux tendances
qui s'affrontent
vous avez Matignon et l'Élysée qui ne
savent pas quoi faire mais véritablement
pas quoi faire la ligne de l'Elysée
c'est je me souviens de Jean-Pierre
jouillet maplan en disant ce que tu dois
faire c'est rencontrer tout le monde
après l'issue c'est à toi de la définir
et Matignon n'a pas plus de lignes que
ça je pense que on a réalisé
je dis on parce que ça a été un travail
collectif ce texte le texte du premier
octobre 2014 la loi qui porte mon nom a
été approuvée à l'Assemblée au Sénat
dans les mêmes termes et à l'unanimité
et on a travaillé je crois avec
l'ensemble des groupes politiques qui
étaient traversés par ces différentes
influences je pense qu'on a fait oeuvres
utile et que la segmentation du marché
du t3p qui est issu de la loi thévenou
elle est toujours valable
elle repose non pas sur le prix minimum
non pas sur le temps minimum elle repose
sur l'occupation du domaine public
c'est-à-dire qu'on revient à la source
de ce qu'est la licence du taxi la
licence du taxi c'est une autorisation
de stationnement donc la loi dit depuis
2014 que la distinction entre les taxis
et les VTC se fait sur la base de
l'occupation du domaine public autrement
dit les taxis ont le droit de rouler et
de stationner dans des endroits où les
VTC n'ont pas le droit de rouler ou de
stationner c'est les voies dédiées c'est
les voies de bus c'est les stations de
taxi et on a ajouté la maraude
électronique c'est ça le fondement de la
loi de 2014 qui est à mon avis le seul
critère qui permet de faire cohabiter
une concurrence entre des taxis qui
payent qui payent ce droit là et en
échange du prix de l'autorisation de la
DS de la plaque comme on dit en langage
taxi et bien ils ont des privilèges qui
sont ceux de pouvoir circuler à certains
endroits c'est très important cette
occupation du domaine public parce qu'on
voit bien que dans les métropoles
d'aujourd'hui
cette notion va avoir de plus en plus
d'importance avec des voix interdites à
la circulation avec des voix dédiées
avec des pistes cyclables l'occupation
du domaine public c'est un bien enfin le
domaine public est un bien et donc
pouvoir l'occuper est un privilège et
c'est ce qui justifie donc la licence de
taxi je pense qu'on a fait une œuvre
utile premièrement parce que le
numérique c'est pas le Far West c'est
pas moi qui le dit c'est le Ministre de
l'économie actuelle Bruno Le Maire hier
je crois en parlant d'un autre sujet sur
les influenceurs oui le numérique c'est
pas le Far West il fallait donc mettre
des règles sur les VTC ça c'est le
premier point deuxième point il fallait
aussi moderniser les taxis donc la loi
2014 c'est un équilibre c'est un
équilibre entre modernisation des taxis
d'une part de mémoire il doit y avoir 12
ou 13 articles la moitié sont consacrés
à la modernisation des taxis
je vous donne un exemple que vous
connaissez c'est l'obligation de la
carte bleue mais découlant non pas de la
loi mais du rapport qui avait préparé
cette loi il y a aussi les forfaits
aéroports qui ont été mis en place à
cette époque qui ont modernisé je crois
profondément les taxis et puis il y a ce
qu'on fait les taxis eux-mêmes notamment
avec les applications numériques donc
c'était d'abord moderniser les taxis qui
en avaient bien besoin et deuxièmement
réglementer les les VTC et donc je pense
que cette loi elle a été utile parce que
le secteur
et j'insiste là dessus le rapport que
j'ai remis au Premier ministre fin avril
2014 c'est un métier d'avenir des
emplois pour la France je suis persuadé
que ce secteur va continuer à créer des
emplois en
somme le gâteau va augmenter il va
augmenter tout simplement parce que on a
besoin de mobilité dans nos métropoles
les transports en commun même s'ils sont
fortement développés à Paris ne
suffisent pas à couvrir ses besoins et
donc il faut développer ces services moi
je n'ai jamais voulu interdire uber en
France j'ai voulu poser des règles et
c'est d'ailleurs on va peut-être y
revenir dans les contacts que j'ai pu
avoir avec Emmanuel Macron avec Bercy ou
avec Jacques Attali que vous avez aussi
auditionné c'était une grande crainte
c'est à dire que la loi interdit Juber
ce que nous avons interdit c'est Hubert
pop Hubert pop à l'époque c'est un
service qui fait de chacun d'entre nous
un chauffeur potentiel c'est sans règles
sans aucune garantie même de d'assurance
ou de sécurité routière tout un chacun
se transformait le soir après le boulot
en chauffeur ça ça a été interdit et il
fallait le faire en revanche j'ai
considéré très vite qu'il fallait des
concurrents au taxi à condition que
c'est concurrent respectent un minimum
de règles du jeu et donc la règle du jeu
qui a été qui a été créé c'est cette
fameuse occupation du domaine public qui
est aujourd'hui une règle qui permet à
chacun de se développer d'autres sujets
sont évidemment apparus depuis 10 ans
des sujets très importants on y
reviendra sans doute sujet notamment du
droit du travail pour les chauffeurs VTC
sur lesquels vous avez dit que je
continuais à travailler moi j'essaye de
porter l'idée que en effet le numérique
et la responsabilité le numérique et le
modèle social ça peut marcher ensemble
on peut à la fois utiliser les outils du
numérique et en même temps être attaché
à un modèle social français à un modèle
européen mais pas seulement parce que la
question du droit du travail pour les
chauffeurs Hubert c'est pas qu'une
question franco-française c'est pas
qu'une question européenne j'entends
souvent dire que notre pays est
ultra administré que le code du travail
etc quand on voit les prises de position
de l'État de Californie aux États-Unis
on voit bien que la question de quelle
protection sociale pour les chauffeurs
ubérisés et pour les travailleurs de
plateforme plus généralement c'est une
question qui touche l'ensemble du monde
à travers les outils numériques donc je
pense qu'on a fait œuvre utile je pense
qu'on a permis de développer ce secteur
et je pense qu'il va continuer à se
développer la question de l'influence
moi j'ai vu arriver des amendements d'un
peu partout
comment dire je pense que j'avais chopé
un peu le totem de l'immunité en langage
Koh-Lanta parce que comme j'avais réussi
à lever les blocages comme j'avais
réussi à mettre fin au blocage du
périphérique
ou violence
le gouvernement
n'ont pas donné carte blanche j'y
reviendrai peut-être puisqu'il y a eu
des contacts assez réguliers mais en
tout cas m'a laissé faire et à jouer le
jeu d'abord d'un rapport puisque j'étais
médiateur rapport remis à Manuel Valls
entre temps Jean-Marc Ayrault avait
démissionné remplacé par Manuel Valls
donc fin avril je remets ce rapport en
juin je dépose une proposition de loi au
nom du groupe socialiste cette
proposition de loi on me donne du temps
parlementaire le gouvernement moque 3 du
temps parlementaire c'est même pas une
niche c'est du temps parlementaire
octroyé par le gouvernement
et le et la proposition de loi est votée
à l'Assemblée nationale puis au Sénat et
promulguer le 1er octobre donc je dirais
que jusqu'au 1er octobre
j'ai
voie ouverte pour trouver
un compromis et c'est parce que le texte
était équilibré je crois qu'il a pu être
voté dans les mêmes termes aussi
rapidement et que finalement le
gouvernement qui ne savait pas où aller
à accepter cette solution qui est encore
une solution opérationnelle aujourd'hui
merci c'est très intéressant très utile
moi j'étais particulièrement interpellé
quand vous avez dit que si vous n'étiez
pas intervenu il y aurait peut-être plus
de taxi parisien aujourd'hui à cause de
cette demande que vous avez mentionné de
l'environnement médiatique aussi de la
popularité initiale de l'offre des VTC
en particulier du beurre je trouve que
c'est assez frappant
cet équilibre dont vous parlez qui a été
soutenu par le gouvernement qui a porté
une réponse à l'interrogation du
gouvernement est-ce que vous considérez
qu’il a continué à être maintenu dans
les initiatives suivantes au moins
jusqu'en 2017 on pourra peut-être parler
d'ailleurs de la suite mais au moins en
tout cas lorsque cette majorité a été au
pouvoir est-ce que vous avez senti cette
même volonté d'équilibre dans l'action
des pouvoirs publics
plus ou moins plus ou moins
mais mais je sais qu'il le sait je
trouve que la loi grand guillaume
est allé trop loin
sur un point elle a remis en cause le
statut de la location-gérance on rentre
dans la technicité du statut du taxi
mais c'est un point qui moins me tient à
cœur parce que vous savez que chez les
taxis il y a trois statuts artisans
salariés et locataire et les locataires
ont toujours été les parents pauvres du
système des taxis
il loue tout il loue la plaque
l'autorisation mais il loue aussi la
voiture et la radio puisqu’il souvent il
loue aussi aux grandes compagnies de
taxi et j'avais souhaité parce que je
considérais que c'était aussi ma mission
en tant que député socialiste de traiter
cette question de la location et j'avais
créé un statut de locataire gérant qui a
été remis en cause par la loi grand
Guillaume
je trouve que
c'est une disposition qui n'est pas
allée dans le bon sens pour le reste sur
les VTC
la ligne rouge pour l'instant n'a pas
été franchie c'est-à-dire que l'idée que
c'est
l'espace public qui segmente le marché
ça n'a pas été remis en cause donc tant
que ça n'est pas bien en cause
c'est très bien je considère que c'est
ça la vraie ligne rouge attention parce
qu'il y a des tentatives je vais vous
donner un exemple très précis Hubert a
soumis ma loi et d'ailleurs toutes les
lois les lois suivantes aussi au crash
test juridique d'ailleurs Hubert me
l'avait fait savoir faut bien comprendre
une chose c'est que moi j'ai rencontré
une fois
Pierre
Dimitri gore Conti c'était le 27
février 2024 dans le cadre de la
médiation j'ai rencontré tous les
acteurs oui j'ai 24 je me projette
2014 et donc j'ai rencontré tous les
acteurs ça a duré des heures et des
heures ici pas très loin salle Colbert
ou avait eu lieu la première réunion
plénière j'ai d'abord fait du bilatéral
avec chacun des acteurs et ensuite
réunion plénière quand j'ai vu Hubert
il était accompagné de son cabinet
d'avocat et de lobbying donc Thema Saman
qui à l'époque conseiller Hubert qui est
venu ici à l'Assemblée nationale et le
directeur général du Air France m'a dit
moi vous faites ce que vous voulez vous
êtes député c'est vous qui faites la loi
je ne participerai pas physiquement aux
réunions vous aurez comme sleeping
partner mon cabinet d'avocat qui sera
présent mais qui ne dira rien
vous légiférer dans le sens que vous
souhaitez nous
on va attaquer votre loi si vous faites
une loi on attaquera toutes les toutes
les dispositions ils ont gagné sur un
seul point ils ont tout fait le Conseil
d'État l'Union européenne le Conseil
constitutionnel ils ont attaqué ils ont
gagné sur un seul point à travers une
QPC ils ont remis en cause
l'impossibilité que j'avais mis dans la
loi de faire à la fois du taxi et du VTC
qui est un problème qui est un problème
parce que si l'un le taxi peut emprunter
les voies de bus s'il est lui-même VTC
vous voyez que quand il est contrôlé il
peut dire que tantôt il est VTC tantôt
il est taxi je pense que c'est un
problème je pense qu'il faut segmenter
les choses entre taxi et VTC ils font le
même travail mais pas avec les mêmes
règles donc
uber a été un partenaire pendant toute
cette période là vraiment dormant
présent via son cabinet de lobbying mais
en ne faisant aucune proposition alors
que les VTC français
chauffeur privé
vaisselle berguerre
IV vaisselle berguer qui est un acteur
important de de cette année-là et de et
même de secteur là faisait les
propositions mais Hubert jamais et donc
ils avaient pour objectif de casser la
loi derrière après le vote de la loi
est-ce que
dernière question de ma part sur cette
période
est-ce que vous vous pouvez vous vous
avez fait allusion dans votre propos
liminaire nous parler un peu de la
nature des échanges que vous avez eu
avec Emmanuel Macron avec
d'ailleurs d'autres représentants de
Bercy puisque vous avez dit c'est la
position de Bercy avant même qu'Emmanuel
Macron devienne ministre quels étaient
leurs préoccupations quelles étaient
leurs priorité dans ce débat donc
on nomme médiateur la semaine suivante
on me m'adjoint deux au fonctionnaires
Julie Bonamy qui est désigné par le
ministère des Finances et André dorsaux
qui est désigné par l'intérieur donc
vous voyez tout de suite le rapport de
force intérieur pro taxi finance
économie pro VTC Julie Bonamy est une
inspectrice des Finances qui maintenant
travaille je crois dans le dans le privé
en Asie
brillantissime et and ré dorsaux est en
ancien sous-préfet qui va ensuite avoir
un rôle important puisqu'il sera
responsable de la commission du t3p qui
sera mise en place suite à suite à la
loi et je travaille en toute confiance
avec ces deux administrateurs qui vont
avec moi élaborer le rapport et Bercy
et alors au début il y a un jeu de rôle
pour savoir où auront lieu les auditions
chacun voulant que les auditions aient
lieu chez lui vous connaissez
l'administration française donc
merci voulait que ça soit merci et André
dorsaux vous voulez que ça soit à
Beauvau je leur ai dit moi je suis
député donc ça va être à l'Assemblée
nationale donc ça a commencé ça a
commencé comme ça
et puis on a vu les cabinets
ministériels des différents ministres
et puis un jour Julie Bonamy je me
souviens très bien et venu me voir elle
m'a dit je pense que ça serait bien que
vous puissiez rencontrer Jacques Attali
je suis dit mais c'est ça serait bien ou
où il le faudrait il le faudrait et donc
j'ai été rencontré Jacques Attali je
rencontrais pour la première fois de ma
vie
[Musique]
je n'avais jamais rencontré Emmanuel
Macron
on s'est tutoyé d'emblée il a fait
preuve comme à son habitude de beaucoup
de d'aisance relationnelles on était
tout de suite
deux hommes de la même génération qui
devions nous entendre et nous parler de
jeunes hommes qui comprenaient la
révolution du Mérite les nouveaux usages
très bien
et donc il m'a fait comprendre que il
fallait pas
faire de mal à uber en France moi je lui
ai dit
ça tombe bien moi je veux faire de mal à
personne ce que je veux pas c'est que
les anciens soient remplacés par les
nouveaux parce que au final on aura rien
gagné si c'est mettre des chauffeurs VTC
et à l'époque on parlait même pas du
statut des chauffeurs VTC mais si c'est
prendre les anciens les enlever les
20000 chauffeurs de taxis parisiens et
les remplacée par 20000 autres on n'aura
rien gagné donc essayons de travailler
intelligemment sur la base du compromis
et des deux jambes que j'avais essayé de
de théoriser
ce qu'il a compris ce qu'il a admis
un peu comme Attali lavé admis et à
partir de là je n'ai plus revu je ne
l'ai plus revu jusqu'à la jusqu'au vote
de la loi du 1er octobre 2014
et je n'ai pas subi je n'ai pas le
sentiment d'avoir subi de pression ou
d'influence de sa part ça c'est clair
après je vous le redis Bercy était très
attentif à l'idée que on puisse ouvrir
la concurrence pour pour uber et bobo en
revanche
de la de la restreindre au maximum mais
l'influencer le lobbying sur ces sujets
là je me dois de vous le dire était
quand même partagé c'est à dire que tout
le monde faisait du lobbying
au moment de la loi sur les taxis il est
de notoriété publique que les taxis ont
une force de frappe médiatique et de
lobbying importante et mon rôle c'était
aussi de les convaincre qu'il devait
eux-mêmes se moderniser et changer
j'insiste là-dessus parce que il faut
pas non plus il n'y a pas d'un côté les
gentils de l'autre côté les les méchants
tout le monde
avait ses entrées ou à ses entrées
encore aujourd'hui au plus haut niveau
de de l'État la première fois que j'ai
rencontré Nicolas Rousselet c'était ici
même à l'Assemblée nationale dans le
bureau de Claude Bartolone président de
l'Assemblée nationale donc tout le monde
a ses entrées
l'attitude du maire d'ailleurs de ce
point de vue là je pense que
aujourd'hui j'ai pas d'informations
vraiment à vous donner ou à vous
dévoiler mais il me semble que la
présence du Berre auprès des autorités
aujourd'hui et sans doute beaucoup plus
forte qu'à l'époque qu'à l'époque où ils
arrivaient seulement et où leur attitude
était une attitude qui avait été
théorisée d'ailleurs par Travis calani
qui dit on enfonce la porte on se met au
centre de la pièce et puis on verra bien
ce qui est ce qu'il arrivera et si on
nous fait des misères et bien on
attaquera devant les tribunaux ce qu'ils
ont fait pour la loi du 1er octobre 2014
aujourd'hui il me semble que la
proximité
la perméabilité entre le gouvernement
des ministres et tout ça et documenté
puisqu'il y a la httvp puisqu'on sait
que Hubert fait du lobbying donc je
pense que la proximité aujourd'hui est
aussi forte voire plus forte encore qu'à
l'époque mais moi
je considère que
je n'ai pas subi d'influence j'ai vu
arriver des amendements des uns et des
autres il y avait des députés
pro-taxi il y avait des députés pro VTC
mais encore une fois à partir du moment
où j'avais réussi à calmer le jeu le
gouvernement avait fait passer le
message de laisser tes venus faire sa
loi ça va apaiser les choses et ensuite
on verra l'influence dont parle uberfe
révèle l'enquête hubert-five
juste ça c'est pas sur la voie techno
c'est après la loi de nous
c'est à partir de 2015 moi comme vous le
savez à partir de là à partir de
l'automne 2014 je ne suis plus dans ce
jeu là je ne suis plus dans le jeu mais
j'ai constaté à travers l'enquête
hubert-fice que les SMS
[Musique]
Mark Magan je n'ai jamais rencontré j'ai
jamais vu le lanceur d'alerte qui est à
l'origine de hubert-five je ne l'ai
jamais vu je dis pas que si il était
venu me voir je l'aurais pas reçu mais
en tout cas personne n'est venu me voir
et je pense que je tenais suffisamment
solidement la barre pour ne pas me
laisser influencer ni par les uns ni par
les autres ni par Hubert ni par J7
et donc juste pour clarifier donc de ce
que vous avez en tout cas observez vous
lors de votre travail sur le sujet la
nature comme l'intensité des pratiques
de lobbying des taxis ou des VTC étaient
assez comparables
elle était nature différente les taxis
étaient étaient
ultra représentés 23 organisations
syndicales dont une organisation
syndicale représentant directement les
intérêts de la G7
avec des chauffeurs donc des gens qui
avaient tenu le volant ou qui tenaient
encore le volant et en face vous aviez
des startupeurs faut bien voir que en
phase vous aviez des jeunes qui venaient
de d'acheter sortaient tout juste
d'acheter et qui voulait qui voulait
créer leur boîte
ce qui était difficile c'était
l'ambiance l'ambiance encore une fois
c'était une ambiance très pro-hubert ce
n'est plus du tout le cas les choses ont
complètement changé les choses ont
changé en matière de de presse de
pression médiatique aujourd'hui regardez
la couverture médiatique du Berre c'est
souvent pour déplorer que la qualité de
service a baissé de dire qu'il y a
des agressions de remettre en cause la
rentabilité du un modèle de parler
évidemment du droit du travail des des
chauffeurs donc quand vous prenez la
presse si vous faites une revue de
presse sur uber depuis un an ça n'a rien
à voir avec l'ambiance de l'époque qui
était une ambiance et cette maison elle
est il y a des fenêtres ouvertes il y a
des portes ouvertes donc elle reçoit
cette ambiance évidemment moi j'ai des
collègues députés qui me disaient mais
tu étais un ringard tu es un ringard
parce que parce que tu défends les taxis
non je défendais pas les taxis je
défends des idées que encore une fois la
révolution numérique c'est pas
pousse-toi de là que je m'y mette voilà
il faut respecter des règles et à partir
de là chacun peut travailler ce et se
développer
dernière question de ma part avant de
laisser à la rapporteur je voudrais
juste venir sur les débats contemporains
vous le savez bien sûr il y a un débat
européen notamment sur directive de
présomption de salariale il y a ce débat
qui agite toutes les grandes économies
vous l'avez mentionné de des États-Unis
au pays européens est-ce qu'on peut
avoir votre éclairage sur la nature de
ces débats aujourd'hui moi je suis
favorable à la directive au projet de
directive européenne je crois que vous
allez auditionner Nicolas Schmitt qui
était qui est à l'origine en partie de
cette directive je pense que ça va dans
le bon sens
moi ce qui me frappe c'est que l'Europe
qu'on a souvent critiqué comme étant une
Europe libérale
je l'ai fait moi-même en tant que
militant élus socialiste plus d'une fois
là elle est moins libérale que le
gouvernement français il faut le
reconnaître
aujourd'hui la régulation du numérique
elle vient plutôt de Bruxelles que de
Paris
DSA DMA tous les textes de population
qui sont des grandes lois des grandes
avancées je pense que l'Europe a un
message à adressé au monde sur la
régulation du numérique elles viennent
de Bruxelles et paradoxalement la France
le gouvernement
particulièrement est un peu en arrière
de la main donc moi je suis très
favorable à cette directive et je
travaille
aussi avec des chauffeurs VTC vous avez
dit que je continuais à travailler sur
ces sujets là moi je travaille sur une
autre piste ou une piste complémentaire
qui est le coopérativisme pour faire
simple
je pense que vous savez les coopératives
pour moi qui suis bourguignon et et qui
a un peu de connaissances de l'histoire
viticole les coopératives agricoles sont
nées souvent des preuves difficiles dans
l'agriculture et c'est un moyen de
rassembler les gens et de concilier à la
fois le le désir d'être entrepreneur
d'entreprendre une forme de liberté les
entreprises et puis une forme de
protection donc nous travaillons avec
quelques amis
chauffeurs VTC
avocat syndicaliste nous avons créé une
coopérative de chauffeurs BTC qui est
basé en Seine-Saint-Denis et qui a pour
objectif non pas de concurrencer uber
parce que concurrence et Hubert il
faudrait des milliers de chauffeurs mais
qui a pour objectif de proposer un autre
modèle au chauffeur VTC et de leur faire
comprendre qu'un autre modèle est
possible donc oui il faut une directive
européenne oui le gouvernement français
doit évoluer et bouger sur ses positions
qui sont aujourd'hui
qui ne sont plus en accord avec les
conditions de travail le niveau de la
commission prise par Hubert et les
plateformes BTC vous savez qu'il y a des
plateformes BTC françaises je veux faire
de la pub à personne mais vous avez
quand même des plateformes des
applications heetch notamment qui se
posent des questions sur le niveau de la
rémunération donc oui c'est un problème
il faut traiter cette question là et le
gouvernement français doit bouger et
aller dans le sens de la directive
merci merci beaucoup pour l'ensemble de
ces éléments même si
peu de temps après l'adoption de la loi
vous vaquez à d'autres
aventures je dirais néanmoins c'est de
suite après l'adoption de cette loi que
les uberphales en fait nous révèlent un
lobbying très intensif du Berre
vis-à-vis du ministre de l'économie de
l'époque dans cet environnement très
favorable idéologiquement à Hubert
d'ailleurs les Hubert-Félix nous nous
révèle ce qu'on pouvait pressentir à
l'époque c'est à dire les économistes
payées pour faire des études d'un site
pipeau dont on connaît enfin dans les
conclusions sont déjà définies à
l'avance les achats de pages dans les
médias avec faux articles pour pour
renforcer cette
ce climat idéologique
favorable à Hubert et qui vise à
ringardiser à ringardiser les taxis
peu de temps après que la loi soit
adoptée
Emmanuel Macron arrive environ il est
arrivé au ministre de l'Économie depuis
5 semaines à Bercy et cas de figures
d'Hubert arrive à Bercy 13 calanique le
vice-président du groupe David plouf
l'ancien conseiller de Barack Obama et
Pierre Dimitri gorcoti des Gets d'Hubert
pour l'Europe de l'Ouest c'est ce que
nous révèle les hubert-files et Marc
Magan qui était présent à cette
rencontre résum ainsi à ses
collaborateurs en un mot spectaculaire
du jamais vu on quitte Bercy et on file
à l'aéroport je vous tape un rapport
dans la journée beaucoup de boulot à
venir mais on va danser bientôt donc on
sent la fête pour Hubert et dans un
compte rendu rédigé par Hubert c'est
représentant décrit leur satisfaction
d'être vraiment totalement sur la même
ligne que Bercy globalement l'objectif
du ministère de l'Économie et d'avancer
afin de clore le dossier VTT
en évitant que trop de barrières soient
imposées au développement du secteur VTC
et en fait dans les notes
uberfall ce que la presse
nous révèle on comprend que Hubert en
fait soulève à Bercy qu'ils ont beaucoup
d'inquiétudes quand on l'a mise en œuvre
de votre loi de la loi TV venue et
qu'ils ont aussi des inquiétudes sur la
durée de formation des chauffeurs et
pour eux c'est c'est des freins au
développement de leur activité et
alors que dans votre loi il me semble
que la question du père pop
était aussi présente dans le texte de
loi et que normalement l'application
uberpop devait être interdite de par de
par cette loi
les hubert-félices nous révèle qu'en
fait les dirigeants du maire vont mener
un lobbying intentif pour développer à
nouveau un détricoter finalement une
partie de votre loi puisque le 20
janvier 2015 une deuxième rencontre a
lieu entre 13 Kalani qui Emmanuel Macron
au moment où Hubert est confronté par
une enquête judiciaire et il va y avoir
donc petit à petit seal pour reprendre
les mots du ministre de l'époque
lui-même qui parlait du deal qui va
finalement permettre à Hubert de
s'engager à arrêter uberpop mais bon la
loi lui l'obligeait de fait et
dans ce deal finalement Emmanuel Macron
va alléger va faire une licence Lite
pour les VTC et c'est à l'allaagement
significatif des conditions
requises pour exercer le statut de VTC
va permettre à Hubert justement de
recruter beaucoup plus de VTC d'envahir
le marché
j'imagine que vous soit vous avez suivi
un peu à l'époque de parce que je sais
personnellement que quand on rentre dans
le sujet du t3p on en est vite passionné
voilà et que on a du mal à voir
l'actualité sans
sans s'y intéresser et j'imagine que les
révélations des hyperphales aussi vous a
motivé à rentrer dans ce dossier qu'elle
regarde avez-vous par rapport à cela
parce que finalement est-ce qu'un deal
était même nécessaire c'est-à-dire que
entre ceux du gouvernement qui était
plutôt pro-taxé ce qui était prohubert
la nécessité d'interdire uberpop qui
vraiment contrevenait énormément à
l'ensemble des lois était-il nécessaire
de faire un deal pour en finir avec
uberpop
non non la réponse est non vous l'avez
dit vous-même c'est que Hubert pop
sous le coup de la loi du 1er octobre
2014 de toute façon était interdit et
appelé à disparaître donc c'était pas
une concession
Hubert en arrêtant Hubert pop ne faisait
pas une concession c'était l'application
de la loi encore une fois moi je ne peux
pas me prononcer sur les rencontres qui
ont eu lieu à cette période entre le
ministre de l'économie et les
représentants du Berre je n'en ai pas eu
connaissance je vais pas chercher à en
avoir
mais force est de constater que
celui qui était secrétaire général
adjoint de l'Elysée puis ministre de
l'Économie puis président de la
République
elle mérite d'une certaine cohérence
c'est-à-dire que pour lui et il la redit
lors de son intervention du 14 juillet
suite aux révélations de bafaite il le
referait je crois que c'est ces mots
parce que il faut rencontrer et les
entreprises bon la cohérence de
d'Emmanuel Macron c'est de dire en gros
si j'ai bien compris c'est de dire
vaut mieux que ça vaut mieux être
chauffeur VTC que tenir que tenir les
murs c'est ce qu'il a dit lors d'une
interview je crois à Mediapart en
campagne présidentielle avant sa
première élection donc
oui sauf que la situation aujourd'hui
elle a changé la situation de l'emploi
n'est pas la même la situation de
l'emploi en France est la profondément
évolué depuis cette période là et
deuxième sujet c'est le sujet de la
dégradation
de la qualité de service du Berre et les
problèmes juridiques que ça pose donc on
ne peut pas on peut lui reconnaître une
cohérence
idéologique finalement de dire moi je
préfère que ces jeunes-là soient
chauffeur VTC quitte à ce que la
plateforme leur prélève 20 25 % et que
l'algorithme les pistes partout je
préfère ça plutôt qu'il soit au chômage
oui enfin sauf que la question de la
protection sociale de ces jeunes là
parce qu'ils sont pas tous jeunes elles
se posent aujourd'hui et et elle se pose
tellement que vous voyez bien
aujourd'hui que l'évolution c'est que
les jeunes ou moins jeunes qui
commencent la carrière comme VTC sont de
plus en plus nombreux aujourd'hui à
aspirer à être taxi et il passe les
concours enfin il passe la formation
taxi c'est pas un concours c'est une
formation mais ils vont dans des écoles
de taxi et donc il y a d'où l'importance
de la formation moi je
j'ai été clair depuis le début je pense
qu'il faut une formation
euh de haut niveau il s'agit pas
seulement de conduire d'un point un
point B une personne en toute sécurité
bon déjà c'est le minimum ce qui est pas
toujours le cas mais en plus il faut une
formation oui formation en anglais parce
qu'on est un pays touristique ça va ça
va sans dire formation au commerce parce
que c'est un métier de commerce
etc etc des services donc je je
revendique l'idée que oui il fallait une
formation et que ça faisait partie de la
réglementation et un des problèmes
posés au VTC aujourd'hui que ne prend
pas assez en compte à mon avis le
gouvernement c'est au-delà du statut
c'est que on a donc
les chiffres sont difficiles à trouver
même avec l'immatriculation des VTC on
n'a pas de chiffres précis
ça c'est un point qu'il faut quand même
souligner c'est à dire que dans le
rapport que j'avais fait il y avait un
observatoire de la mobilité à l'échelle
parisienne
je pense que ce rapport n'est pas encore
obsolète même 10 ans après un peu moins
de 10 ans après il y a des propositions
qui seraient bon de reprendre de la même
manière j'avais inscrit dans la loi
parce que j'avais un peu pas beaucoup
d'expérience de parlementaires mais un
peu d'expérience du Parlement j'avais
inscrit le fait qu'il y aurait un
rapport sur l'évaluation de la mise en
oeuvre de cette loi
rapport qui a mis plus d'un an et demi à
sortir il a fallu d'ailleurs que je pose
une question d'actualité ici même pour
que finalement en face ce rapport
d'évaluation peut-être que d'ailleurs on
voulait pas faire ce report d'évaluation
parce qu'on ne voulait pas
révéler un certain nombre d'influences
de rendez-vous je ne sais pas mais en
tout cas
l'idée qu'il faut réévaluer cette loi
qui peut-être pas la loi la plus
parfaite du monde qu'il faut reprendre
le rapport de d'avril 2014 qu'il faut
faire des voies dédiées entre Paris
intra-muros et les aéroports j'en
profite je suis là je plaide je pense
que c'est aussi comme ça qu'on va
permettre une plus grande fluidité le
fait qu'il faut sans doute mieux
associer la collectivité locale et le
Grand Paris écoutez l'Autorité de
régulation à Londres transport London
elle ne dépend pas ni du ministère de
l'économie d'une ministère d'intérieur
et même pas des transports elle dépend
de Londres donc il faudra bien aller
vers une une gestion et une vision très
précise un observatoire de la demande
des besoins aujourd'hui on a 60000
chauffeurs VTC plus ou moins actif ils
doivent être protégés et on doit les
inciter à améliorer la qualité de
service parce que finalement
que c'est les clients qui sont pas
contents et parfois il y a même des
procédures qui sont engagées contre
certains chauffeurs VTC d'où
l'importance de la formation et ce
secteur là est un secteur qui va
continuer à créer
des emplois et moi je suis frappé pour
intervenir de temps en temps auprès de
chauffeurs VTC ou de chauffeur de taxi
de voir à quel point c'est un des seuls
secteurs de l'artisanat qui recrute
massivement aujourd'hui qui trouve ces
jeunes chauffeurs qui deviennent VTC qui
s'aperçoivent que finalement ça ne
suffit pas ils vont à la fois constituer
un patrimoine avec le rachat d'une
licence quand il souhaite en acheter ils
vont avoir du boulot pour faire bouillir
la marmite et c'est un métier
intéressant important
économiquement et touristiquement pour
pour la France et pour Paris
je vais quand même revenir en arrière
je pense que c'est quand même le point
de départ de notre enquête parlementaire
quand vous vous avez cette mission vous
dites et vous insistez là-dessus vous
estimez que votre rôle de député de
médiateur et donc de définir l'intérêt
général en essayant de voir justement
jusqu'où trouver un compromis entre des
intérêts divergents bien
et on voit bien que ça correspond à une
certaine étape dans la stratégie du
Berck et dire bon on fait pas un
lobbying
intensif sur les décideurs publics à cet
état à cette étape là on observe on a
nos avocats lobbyistes
et de toute façon on va régler ça dans
les tribunaux une fois que la loi est
adoptée on est dans une nouvelle étape
là les hubert-faces nous révèle comment
Google facilite la mise en relation très
manuel Macron 13 kalanique le rôle aussi
d'autres grands oligarques tout cela est
très intéressant de voir comment cet
écosystème
rentre en contact vous avez bien
confirmé que
ce qu'on appelle le deal abandon du père
pop facilitation sur la formation donc
modification de la réglementation de
l'autre côté n'était pas si nécessaire
puisque Hubert pop c'était pas était de
fait interdit par la loi et là on a
vraiment le sentiment qui a une rupture
de déséquilibre à partir de ce moment-là
parce que finalement même il comprit au
niveau de la commande vient la
négociation de Macron est le cadeau qui
finalement est fait à Hubert sur
l'abaissement des exigences sur la
formation
relevez pas du portefeuille du ménis de
l'économie
et pourtant c'est Emmanuel Macron
comment avez-vous vu ce moment enfin
vous étiez pu en fonction mais est-ce
que vous avez pu suivre ou pas ce moment
où Emmanuel Macron finalement impose ce
dit là qui va à l'encontre en partie de
la loi thévenou alors que ça n'est pas
son portefeuille alors que c'est quelque
part contradictoire avec les
positionnements du ministère transport
et du ministre de l'Intérieur et du
Premier ministre de l'époque
alors je suis plus en fonction je suis
toujours député de Saône-et-Loire et
donc je siège toujours ici et en fait
vous l'avez dit il y a une rupture mais
c'est une nouvelle étape politique dans
le quinquennat de François Hollande ça
correspond c'est pour ça que cette
histoire est très intéressante parce
qu'elle elle l'illustre l'évolution
politique qui a eu lieu à partir de
l'entrée d'Emmanuel Macron au
gouvernement en septembre 2014 disons
les choses il y a il y a cette histoire
de de d'allègement de formation
uberpop il y a la loi Macron il y a la
loi travail el khomri on est passé dans
une nouvelle étape
et comme on a à la tête de l'État au
plus haut niveau beaucoup d'hésitations
on en avait déjà dans la période
précédente puisque je vous l'ai dit
personne ne savait me dire quelle était
la piste d'atterrissage c'était bien le
tout le problème et c'est bien pour ça
qu'on est venu me chercher on savait pas
comment ATT errir mais on voit bien qu'à
partir de septembre 2014 la pression en
faveur d'une orientation plus libérale
des choses
elle est de plus en plus forte moi je la
constate en tant que député il s'y même
et je vois que texte à prétexte on a
pris un autre chemin
une nouvelle étape nouvelle étape et
tournant libéral avec donc une poursuite
de la de la cohérence du cheminement du
ministre de l'économie de l'époque par
contre sur la loi Macron sur la loi el
khomri même si ça se terminera pour la
loi el khomri sur un 49-3 on est quand
même sur un débat parlementaire autour
de ces textes
concernant
concernant les mesures qui vont
détricoter la loi téflon on n'est pas
sur un débat on n'est pas sur un débat
transparent avec les parlementaires ni
même une discussion à ma connaissance
mais on auditionnera les ministres
des Transports et de l'Intérieur
prochainement pour justement appréhender
cet aspect c'est-à-dire qu'il y a même
pas de débat à l'intérieur du
gouvernement on a l'impression que c'est
Emmanuel Macron qui qui va imposer
ces modifications et qui de toute façon
s'engage dans ces échanges directs avec
les dirigeants du maire au point que ces
derniers par exemple vont dire pour ce
qui est de Maxime druineau qui est
lobbyse du Berre qui était présent à
Bercy lors d'une deuxième rencontre
entre Travis scalinique et Macron
Emmanuel Macron il est favorable à une
licence light pour les VTC et par
conséquent un allégement significatif
des conditions requises renforcées par
la loi thévenou et par la suite il
résume le plan il dit nous nous sommes
mis d'accord avec Emmanuel Macron sur un
process en deux temps un proposer un ou
plusieurs amendements à la Loi Macron
avant demain soir afin de modifier la
réglementation actuelle introduite par
la loi TV nous deux nous avons une
fenêtre de 4 semaines pour mener une
campagne de communication avec Macron
afin de faire accepter l'idée qu'une
licence VTC light serait une solution
pour l'emploi et la mobilité dans ce
contexte il s'agira de trouver le moment
opportun pour rédiger un décret
abolissant le régime proposé par la loi
thévenus et introduire une
réglementation plus et c'est ce qui va
donner par la suite notamment les
amendements de Luc Bello d'ailleurs sur
ces amendements de Luc Bello sur les
échanges les amendements de Luc Bello on
a le nom de Julie Bonamy
qui ressort de et que vous avez cité
précédemment puisqu'elle était nommée
par Bercy c'est ça pour travailler avec
vous sur le sur la médiation puis projet
de loi et donc
Julie Bonamy qui est donc conseillère
d'Emmanuel Macron
va être nommé par va être cité pardon
par un
dirigeant du Berre
quand il va saluer en fait le travail
qui a pu faire Luke bailot sur leur
volonté de de modification d'amendement
il va dire
que c'est non j'arrive plus retrouver la
phrase enfin un grosso modo que c'est un
beau travail quasiment digne de Julie de
Julie Bonamy quoi si je comprends bien
donc on voit bien la
proximité pas simplement idéologique
culturelle mais de défense d'intérêt de
de lobbyiste est-ce que vous aviez vous
aviez vent de tout cela à ce moment-là
en tant que député ou est-ce que c'est
des choses que vous avez découvert après
lors des révélations du ber fail non moi
je j'ai pas j'ai pas connaissance de ça
sur le sur le sur le fait
d'abord parce que j'ai continué à suivre
ces questions là mais je voulais pas
revenir sur un sur un terrain que je que
voilà que je connaissais trop bien
[Musique]
j'ai découvert j'ai découvert ça comme
tout le monde
l'amendement de de Luc Bello là le petit
passage qu'on a qu'on a tous vu au
moment des HUF files
mais j'avais pas connaissance de ça bon
voilà je me permets aussi cette remarque
personnelle je pense que quand il est
arrivé ce qu'il est ce qui m'est arrivé
certes par ma faute mais quand il est
arrivé ce qu'il est arrivé je pense pas
que chez Hubert on
en soit été enfin on a été mécontent de
de ça évidemment que
pardon de parler de moi la troisième
personne mais tu es venu il avait essayé
de garantir un équilibre
nous n'étant plus là ça facilitait sans
doute
un peu les choses pour
faire pencher le fléau de la balance
dans un sens plus libéral qui est encore
une fois correspondait aussi
à l'orientation générale qui a prise le
gouvernement et le président de la
République à partir de septembre 2014
alors il y a cette période là des
huberphales et puis il y a la suite la
suite
vous êtes intervenus tout à l'heure pour
dire pour exprimer en fait les
recommandations que vous pouviez avoir
vous sur comment continuer à défendre
cette équilibre dans le t3p entre ces
deux façons de remplir une même tâche
transportée des personnes à un point A à
un point B mais avec des réglementations
différentes des contraintes différentes
et ces deux métiers qu'il faut donc
selon vos propos préservés dans leur
juste équilibre
et c'est vrai que ce qu'on voit depuis
l'adoption de la loi de votre loi c'est
que sur bien d'ombre de points elle
n'est toujours pas appliquée
l'interdiction de la maraude
électronique n'est absolument pas
appliqué
quel regard portez-vous là-dessus
sachant que la loi grand Guillaume va
connaître la même chose c'est-à-dire
qu'il va y avoir un temps de dingue
avant que les décrets d'applications
soient pris et sur bien des aspects la
loi grandillaume non plus n'est pas
appliquée donc le l'équilibre de base
trouvé
un moment et qui peut être considéré par
certains comme un peu trop favorable
taxi par rapport au VTC d'autres vont
considérer au contraire que c'est un
compromis qui déjà permet à un secteur
qui instaure une concurrence déloyale
vis-à-vis de la profession de taxi de
pouvoir grignoter mais de fait même le
compromis n'est pas appliqué qu'est-ce
qu'elle regarde vous portez là-dessus
c'est un peu le drame de de notre
mission et de notre fonction de
législateur c'est de constater
malheureusement quelques années après
que ce qu'on a produit comme texte ne
rentre pas en application je vais vous
faire une réponse très générale c'est un
des drames français c'est de constater
que on fait beaucoup de communication
sur des lois on en parle beaucoup et
puis finalement elles sont pas elles
sont pas appliquées moi je pense qu'il
faut continuer dans la même dans la même
veine c'est-à-dire qu'il faut continuer
à moderniser les taxis il y a encore des
choses à faire je vous ai cité quelques
exemples
le forfait aéroport par exemple pour
revenir sur ce sujet là
quand vous habitez Malakoff vous avez
des gens qui prennent leur balise et qui
traversent le périphérique pour
bénéficier du forfait aéroport quand
est-ce qu'on va réfléchir en termes de
Grand Paris sur la question de la
mobilité donc il faut des voies dédiées
pour aller aux aéroports donc il faut
que le forfait aéroport soit étendu faut
sortir de cette idée que Paris c'est
juste Paris intra-muros
en deçà de de du périphérique il faut
donc continuer il faut faire ce registre
national des taxis de la disponibilité
des taxis c'est-à-dire qu'il faut que
les applications qui veulent pouvoir
géolocaliser en temps réel un taxi libre
puisse le faire c'est ce que le
ministère des Transports a lancé c'est
le point taxi bon mais ça personne le
sait tout le monde s'en fiche donc il
faut continuer à moderniser et il faut
continuer à réglementer de la même
manière
des VTC on a parlé du droit social et du
droit du travail qui est le plus
important on doit remettre le paquet sur
la qualité de service qui s'est
fortement dégradé chez les chauffeurs
VTC et ça c'est pas admissible on doit
lutter contre les incivilités voire les
agressions qui ont lieu chez les VTC et
chez les taxis aussi là il s'agit de
lutter de manière uniforme donc il faut
continuer ce travail là et il faut
reprendre point par point les différents
articles des lois 2014 2016 et même du
rapport initial je pense que encore une
fois moi je j'ai espoir que ce secteur
là d'activité continue à se développer
et Hubert ne peut pas dire Hubert ne
peut pas dire qu'il a été empêché de se
développer par la loi thévenou c'est pas
vrai c'est pas vrai puisque le nombre de
chauffeurs a explosé on en est paraît-il
après de 60 000 donc personne personne
ne peut dire
que il a été empêché de se développer
c'est c'est je pense en vous parlant
c'est Nicolas Rousselet qui m'avait dit
ça après le vote de la loi il m'avait
dit votre loi est une très bonne loi
parce qu'elle mécontente tout le monde
et c'est souvent l'indice des bonnes
lois et elle m'est contentée aussi
j'essaie qui n'était pas d'accord avec
un certain nombre de de dispositions qui
d'ailleurs les a fait modifiés par la
loi grand Guillaume je pense à la
location gérance dont je parlais tout à
l'heure mais il faut continuer à
moderniser et poser des règles du jeu et
je pense que les règles du jeu des VTC
il est faux de dire que ces règles du
jeu empêchent Hubert de travailler en
France ce n'est pas vrai et c'est pas ça
qui empêche l'entreprise HUBERT de ne
pas être rentable enfin c'est pas c'est
pas la loi thévenou qui empêche Hubert
d'atteindre la rentabilité à l'échelle
française voire mondiale tout ça c'est
c'est on raconte des histoires à dormir
debout
on sait bien que cette entreprise elle a
été créée sur un volume de cage très
important avec des dépenses de marketing
et de communication et de lobbying sans
doute aussi parce que il faut payer les
lobbystes à ce niveau là et donc avec
des dépenses qui ont rien à voir avec le
service très important mais c'est pas la
loi des venus qui empêche Hubert de se
développer en revanche ce que le citoyen
tomate est venu aujourd'hui souhaiterait
c'est que les chauffeurs VTC qui ont été
directement impactés par la crise
sanitaire les livreurs aussi qui font
partie de la même catégorie des
travailleurs de plateformes et on a et
qu'on a vu dans nos dans nos villes et
qu'on continue à avoir dans nos villes
sillonner nos villes pour apporter c'est
quoi un beau bun un cheeseburger à
l'autre bout de la ville que ces gens-là
puissent avoir c'est la moindre des
choses un statut une protection des
papiers soit régularisés c'est ça que
doit essayer de faire le gouvernement
français aujourd'hui pour faire en sorte
que le numérique et le modèle social se
soit conciliable
merci beaucoup
monsieur ministre monsieur thévenou on
aura peut-être des questions
complémentaires ou des demandes de
documents et naturellement n'hésitez pas
à faire parvenir d'autres précisions ou
document si ça vous paraît utile à la
commission d'enquête il y a encore deux
mois de travaux à peu près de devant
nous mais l'intervalle je vous remercie
énormément pour à la fois ce témoignage
et cette analyse des enjeux actuels qui
font seront extrêmement précieux pour
notre commission et je vous souhaite une
excellente journée